foreign
with over 20 years of history maps are a
fundamental pillar of Counter-Strike
and in Counter-Strike 2 maps are getting
a new look but don't worry you can still
bring along your countless hours honing
strategies and exploiting every corner
in crevice
took three approaches to improving Maps
while retaining their Rich Legacy first
there are Touchstone Maps classic maps
with solid foundations that players can
use to evaluate gameplay changes from CS
go to Counter-Strike 2.
these have improvements to lighting and
character read but otherwise haven't
been changed
[Music]
next we have upgrades
these are maps that use new source 2
lighting including a physically based
rendering system that produces realistic
materials lighting and Reflections
and finally overhauls
all this maps have been fully rebuilt
from the ground up leveraging all of the
source 2 tools and rendering features
these tools will be available for
Community map makers to make it easier
to build experiment and iterate
upgrades to lighting player read and
materials and Counter-Strike 2. even the
familiar will feel brand new
[Music]
[Applause]